our final presentation
will be by claire barnes uh claire is a
second year masters of religion
candidate at yale divinity school
concentrating in religion and ecology
claire has several fields of interest
including food and religion climate
justice indigenous representation in
international climate forums and
gastronomic archives
she currently works at the beineckey
library and worked at the yale divinity
school
yale divinity special collections this
past summer about which i think we're
going to be hearing some more
claire also holds a masters in
international political theory from the
university of saint andrews and a
bachelor's in religion and philosophy
from emory university please join me in
welcoming claire
[Applause]
hi everyone
so
um as matthew said my name is claire
barnes and i uh study food and religion
um at yale divinity particularly
um religion and ecology and i'm here to
give let's see if i can get this to work
a general highlight from the collection
i think as a student worker in the
collection i would love it if more
people would visit the collection
especially
working within smaller archival spaces
is quite rewarding
for both students and faculty
and then i'm going to be focusing on
um some research that i conducted with
chloe starr who
teaches this class called china missions
and so talking about the ways in which
students utilize the collections in a
classroom setting but also kind of
untangling
some of the questions and possibilities
within missionary archives
and then further areas of study which
are currently still being
catalogued in the andover newton um
collection which has been added to the
yell divinity schools collection
so the history of the yale divinity
school uh collections is that there's
six thousand linear feet of archival
material in our collections
um
which ranges from pamphlets to
microform holdings we also have several
areas of specialization for example
which i will talk about later the china
missions project which
many of the china missionary papers and
as well as
bibles and translations of bibles are
held in this project and they were
acquired in connection with the china
records project
um the himalayan mission archive
collection and was formed in 2008 um as
an amalgamation of four different
archival
organizations and it was transferred to
the yield divinity collection from the
center for the study of world
christianity at the university of
edinburgh
and then finally the divinity school
also has a rich holding of
archives that have been transferred from
the andover newton theological school
and these are still being catalogued and
there are um
there's room in this this collection for
additional
scholarship
for example here is a
papyri from the andover newton
collection
the papyri collection from the andover
newton collection ranges from first to
sixth century ce but this is from the
early fourth century ce
um the collection also contains personal
papers archives of organizations
pamphlets and papers and missionary
postcards images and ephemera
um
we also have a really interesting
collection of translated um bibles
um and also bible folio so these are big
bibles that would be used in a pulpit
setting um so the bible on that you're
seeing right now on the right is quite
huge it's quite large it's like this big
and these are on site
um and thinking about the ways in which
um how can we critically analyze
missionary culture we can think about
the intersection between linguistics and
visual culture within these pieces for
example a lot of these bibles are also
illuminated manuscripts so you can see
here
there's a image of genesis that has been
illustrated
and and thinking about the continuity
between our collections in terms of
visual culture
there are also contemporary forms of of
visual culture that are quite
interesting in the collection these are
two of my favorite pieces from the
collection besides the work that i did
in chloe starr's class um
so on the right you can see here
they're chick tracks and chick tracks
are comic little um comic books that are
that were illustrated by jack teapcic um
since the early
1960s and they document
fringe um
evangelical responses to upheavals in
american culture
and they're often placed in libraries so
students who will go into libraries will
see these chick tract collections and
they'll be inclined by their titles such
as global warming or um
downtown doomtown town
to look at them but they actually um are
quite um fundamental or fundamentalist
and they're
quite conservative but then on the other
end of the spectrum we have these really
interesting pins from the collection
that also kind of we can think about the
evolution of of um religious visual
culture in america particularly with
these pins
um and these are from the henry hale
butcher jr papers um and these pins
range from 1936 to 2013 and as you can
see um this is one of my favorite pins
school of america u.s government
terrorist training and it's not a cue
for people um to think that oh we're
gonna have an interesting conversation
about global warming and evangelical
papers and actually it'll be something
quite different um but these are pins
that were collected um by butcher kind
of in response to many things for so for
example you can see jail bush right
there and there's um
conversations within that we can have
around these pins in terms of both um
spiritual understandings of american
cultural shifts and and social movements
um but also in terms of kind of a
continuity thinking about
missionary culture in in america as well
and then i think as a student in the
archives at least from a student
perspective our archives are a great
place to think about
methodological uncertainties questions
and possibilities for missionary papers
thinking about
holding both
a criticism
of
the work in our collection
as intertangled and colonial and
imperial matrices and then also thinking
about what what these pieces are saying
and what um
the missionaries are reporting on in in
the places that they are so for example
if we can think about geopolitical
shifts in the countries that these
missionaries are in and what their how
they think about them how they think
about their friends and their families
in these countries and so holding both
of those realities and thinking la
minsane was a professor of world
christianity
at yale divinity
and he in particular was interested in
looking at some of the linguistic work
that missionaries had done
and
thinking about broadening
our our use and understanding of
missionary papers um thinking about them
both critically and thinking about their
possibilities
um and the yale edinburgh group on world
christianity in the history of missions
continues his work and this line of
thinking critically about um our pieces
not only in terms of their provenance
but in terms of american imperialism and
also um critical things that we can gain
from them in in terms of social and and
religious commentary um and they meet
every year and they're also meeting in
um 2022 so that will be if so if y'all
are interested in learning more about
um
the development of uh
missionary studies as a discipline and
also rebranded as world christianity
thinking about
disciplinary boundaries within the
archives is quite interesting
so now i'm going to turn to
my
specific research project in china
missions which was with chloe starr
again who is an expert
in
chinese christian theology and has
published an excellent book
on
chinese theologians
but when i had entered her class which
was an interesting hybrid class between
an exhibition style of looking at both
um jesuit like early jesuit missionaries
who were in china um and as well as
translations of the bible and chinese
characters and then so that was kind of
the first part of the class and then the
second part of the class was dedicated
to individual research in the archives
and so when i was thinking about what i
normally study which is religion and
food in an american context
she had pointed me and joan and everyone
in the archives had helped me get to the
albert and celia stewart papers and a
particular addendum that had been
brought to yale divinity and had not yet
been processed
so albert steward was trained as a
biologist but then served as a
university professor at the christian
college at the university of nanjing at
that point it was spelled
with a k and you can trace the evolution
of the college actually in its synthesis
with other universities from the
republican era and to the communist era
but he taught at this university he
taught botany and he ran the um
herbarium there and he was there from
1921 to 1950
and was also like intern during
the japanese invasion
but i had i focused my research project
on his papers and i was interested in
looking at the development of what is
called an agricultural missionary
and thinking about
this in these intersections between
agriculture religion and national memory
and development um
in the in his collection as well there
are a wide variety of things so he has
like diaries and
in in in the addendum which i processed
actually he has um
ration cards from when he was interned
and he has
letters and whatnot and there are also
lantern slides and lantern slides are
small glass slides that you put in a
projector and they're actually quite
heavy so it's interesting to think that
they would carry these around to both
document to their families oh like this
is where i teach for example this is a
image of the campus or these are some of
the challenges that i'm facing in my
work so
um
in this right slide we can see here it's
labeled
wasteful cutting of forests but actually
if we dive deeper into his collection we
can see that
he is engaging with different like
political and policing bodies
during
the kmt government when
um
this this photograph is actually
documenting a moment where
um this is a research forest and there
were
locals who came and chopped down the
wood for
fuel because there was resource
shortages during um japanese invasion
and so he had to engage with different
policing bodies within nanjing at that
time
to
kind of balance his
agricultural work with
the local conditions
and
what's quite interesting about his work
is that he thinks about his
the
um what is often termed by
the university as the christianization
of national life with these christian
colleges he thinks about his work in
terms of land and so he has this
interesting um
uh fusion of thinking about
um
relig his religious experience and his
experience teaching with um his work
outside of the university because
oftentimes
both him and his chinese colleagues
would go out into the
more local areas and they would either
gather plants or they would work on
like local conditions like if there was
um droughts or or whatnot
um
and we have a collection um
thinking about my research in terms of
just his papers i think wasn't um it
wasn't proving fruitful enough so then
looking at other pieces of the
collection
um we have a
repository of agriculture and forestry
notes which is at the college that he
was teaching at within the university
um
and
thinking uh the university itself was
positioning
um
its work in terms of a larger
agricultural policy for china and it
would document um the all of the
professors that had either been engaging
with um agricultural policy talks with
um their the shifting geopolitical um
lines and um entities and then they were
also very concerned and he existed
within this university that was very
concerned about government recognition
of the university
and so thinking
about
his work in particular for me was quite
useful
that he had joined a department with
nation-building aspirations as well
um
okay
and i think that um he collected
um
newspapers from um both
american newspapers and chinese
newspapers that document um
important moments and diplomatic moments
for example um this is at the advent
of
during world war ii and so thinking
about
his role as a missionary in this complex
web of his agricultural work and as well
as um
the history of not on the histories and
the developing histories of not only
china but um in where he was a
missionary but of
the united states and of political
relations um and i think
um what was really important for our
class is
is um teasing out um
our understanding of missionary work in
different places and so in in this
example
i was able to look at kind of this
complex web and matrices of his life um
to
think about how we can push the
boundaries of of missionary work and
world christianity in general
and also what has been really
quite rewarding for me in terms of this
work not only thinking about like
agricultural histories which i don't
think we normally
um
connect with
missionaries and but which i think is
quite relevant in terms of colonization
and imperialization
both here and abroad
but that
the donor
for his collection was his son david
stewart and he
was able to engage with my presentation
and add on
points when i had
done my final presentation for our class
and so i think that in in a smaller
archival space that is in a larger
library network to think about the
relational aspects of our work is quite
important
and he we still email today and he adds
i think great insights into some of the
work that i had been doing particularly
around his father's orientation towards
his teaching and his work
and also on on his experience as
a kid growing up in in china at that
point
and thinking about also his the family
the family legacy and what um as a
student worker um
i which i had transitioned to after this
project it made me think about in what
ways can we better archive our work and
in what ways can we handle our our work
so that it reflects not only um the
complexities of our
um
of the the
donor's life but also of um
of the his continued fam family legacy
um
and his son had actually um
been a professor and he was quite
interested in
seeing the development of of this work
and so i think that is a great
opportunity for students in particular
um
to be involved with
the donors understanding of their own
work and their own
donation
um agricultural histories um
and chinese missionary work are also
very tied to medical histories
and this is an example of another paper
that i worked on
in which
these are the edward l bliss papers that
i catalogued
in addition to the steward papers
and helped with the finding aid for
and this is a really interesting case
because
i had a lecturer in
medicine reached out to me and had asked
are there any connections in these in
these papers
um between agriculture and and medicine
and religion and so this is another
example of kind of the interdisciplinary
work that we can do when we tease out
um the material um in these papers and
this is um
bliss with his students and colleagues
and then this these are examples of what
is in his collection so um from
photographs to letters to passports
which we have
so yell the the yell divinity special
collections are not only a repository
for this rich collection of
chinese material and and missionary
papers
but they're also a repository for the
history of yds and so
the women's center material is the third
collection that i was able to work on as
a student worker
um
and this this collection was actually
quite large it was 30 boxes compared to
stewart's collection was about seven
boxes
um but joan bates forsberg who was the
founder of the women's center
um
was quite heavily involved in
um
creating a network of of female
seminarians
to understand
their role not only as students but in
response to as i've mentioned with the
buttons and the chick tracks in response
to
different moments in american history so
different waves of feminism for example
and also during there are lots of um
material in this collection on um
women's responses to
um the vietnam war and um further like
um
uh industrial like the
military-industrial complex its
development
um and
they were very focused on
not only uh curricular advancements for
using more
inclusive language and in their
curriculum but just creating an
all-inclusive voice for women which
right now is defined by the center as
anyone who self-identifies as a woman
um
and they the current yds women's center
is still in existence and they publish
a journal called voice which is fitting
um for their mission
um
and we continue to collect copies of
voice
um
and so this is another way in which the
yds archive um
really can be a great resource for
students who are interested
in um the development of yds as an
institution
and then these are further areas for
study these are both medieval
manuscripts um from 1500s and these are
in the andover newton collection
this is
illustrated
um biblical text from ezekiel i believe
and then the image on the right is a
kabbalistic text
that has a combination we were looking
at it yesterday of um of hebrew and
other languages
um and so thinking about um the the role
of smaller archival spaces and really
diving and giving access to um to
students um to these like novel um
pieces that most people haven't delved
into yet um and so people can
students in particular working with
professors that have a broader
understanding both linguistically
and materially of the collection can
have like a quite personalized
experience in the yds archives um
thinking about there are many avenues
and rooms for discovery in the archive
as i hope you can you've seen through
this collection as well as my own
research
and there's room for relational um
building within the archive in this way
and so
um
here is my contact information
and if you'd like to contact me that is
my email joan duffy's a senior archivist
in neo archives who can help you
piece through any of your interests that
you have in the collection and then
suzanna still holmer is our main
librarian and she has developed
excellent research guides for further
interdisciplinary connections
between contemporary texts and our
archival material so thank you so much
[Applause]
you mentioned cataloging
when you're talking about the bliss
papers
and i think it's really interesting what
you were saying about donor engagement
have you thought about i mean we're in a
moment right where we're thinking about
how we catalog and how objects have been
catalogued historically talk a little
bit about your work in cataloging and
you're working with a lot of
materials that uh come into play with
current social movements and other
things and how do you sort of navigate
that task
yeah
so when i was first my so my class
project on the steward papers was almost
a hybrid project where i um was able to
delve into um agricultural histories
through
the his lens but also i learned how to
internally catalog materials based off
of yell divinity standards and external
standards but i think that um
particularly for me thinking about
provenance is a really interesting
question and thinking about for the
evolution of world christianity or
missionary studies how that might come
into play um
and i i think that as a young researcher
i think having fresh eyes on
research collections is really important
because we bring in these considerations
and these concerns to the archive space
and then it becomes an intergenerational
task of figuring out how do we
uphold the voices and the narratives
that are in the papers themselves such
as albert stewart but also how do we
interpret them to make them meaningful
for our current context and for our
current critiques and also the
possibilities of missionary work um so i
think hopefully that answers your
question
okay thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you